In this lesson, we're going to learn
about how a gene's expression, is regulated.
>> So let me get this straight, the main difference between a brain
cell, and say, a stomach cell, is just the expression of a gene?
>> Exactly. This gene expression pattern is analgous to
our recipe again. We're going to be looking at how
a cell decides to add a cup of sugar,
versus a tablespoon of sugar, versus No sugar at all.
>> Well, let's go back to our lactose metabolism
example, which the main ingredient is the lactase gene.
>> If we search all across the human genome for
the lactase gene, we'll find it here on chromosome two.
Now, let's zoom in on chromosome two just a little
bit, and we can see what we'd imagine it would look
like. Remember, I'm showing the non-duplicated chromosomes here because this
is what they mainly exist as. In the karyotype here,
we're looking at the duplicated chromosomes, which is why they
look like Xs, but here. They don't. You have two chromosome
2's, one from mom, one from dad. Chromosome
2 is the next largest chromosome in the
whole genome, at approximately 243 million base pairs
long. The lactase gene is located approximately half-way along
Chromosome 2. Remember you've got Two copies, one
of mom's chromosome and one of dad's chromosome. If
we were to zoom into this region of
chromosome two to look further at the lactase gene,
we'd see that it's actually composed of about
17 exons spanning more than 50,000 base pairs
of DNA. After transcription and splicing, removing all
the introns that can be found in this gene
We're left with about 6,200 nucleotide of an
MRNA copy of the lactase gene. Now if
we take a look at that lactase MRNA,
we'll see that between the start and the stop
codon, including the start and stop codon,
we have 5,784 nucleotides of information. Now based
on what you've learned so far, I want you to tell me how many amino
acids would be translated by a ribosome
using this mRNA sequence here. We have 5784
nucleotides, including the start and stop codons and
everything in between. If you need help answering
this question it's probably cause you need to go back and review
some material in lesson three. If you think the genetic code will help
you answer this question, you can find it in the instructor's notes
below. Go ahead and put your best number answer into this text box.